[Music]
a north las vegas family's fight to live
in safer environment continues it's an
update to a story that we first brought
you here last week showing black mold
issue at the rose garden town homes
victoria saha went back there today only
to find that management has not lived up
to their promise they told us last week
denise we went back there today because
shaquira armstrong one of the many
residents living in these unsafe
conditions was supposed to check out of
the hotel that management put her in
while they claimed they were fixing the
mold issue so we went back there to see
if there was any progress
sequoia armstrong was supposed to be
moving into her new temporary unit at
rose garden i found the same exact thing
that was in my unit
mold so instead everything is being
unloaded from the moving truck back into
her old unit they're all molded they're
all infested
they're all leaking plumbing issues
air vent issues
management put armstrong in a hotel from
may 5th until may 9 so they can fix the
black mold issue in her old unit but as
we went to inspect there was no sign of
any work done asbestos still all in the
wall
up and down
mold all around the outside nothing's
changed while we were out there several
residents surrounded us to tell us their
horrific living condition when we first
reported the story last week ferris
state a company out of new york that
owns the complex said they expected all
mold to be removed this week they also
said they put a regional manager and a
facilities manager on site full time to
address this so we went to the leasing
office to ask why armstrong still does
not have a mold free apartment are you
guys going to give her a new unit wait
no comment or why was it okay for her to
be put in a unit with mold again
this was the situation she was trying to
avoid staff refused to answer i was told
there's a full-time regional facilities
manager and a manager on site to discuss
this for a residence
that was a resident nearby who also says
she's been dealing with this for years
we were told there was a regional
facilities manager as well on site full
time
to discuss these issues on our site who
told you that
new york
is fair
it's just us here something has to give
we can't keep staying here
we can't keep doing this
i've been in contact with the ferris
state company they told me they would
have an update on the work being done i
reached out again after visiting the
complex asking for that update and
sharing that we didn't find a facilities
manager on site like they promised i'm
still waiting for them to explain
themselves as for armstrong she has to
go back to the hotel for the next few
days denise